thanksgiving is next week and if you
still have stains on your carpet from
last thanksgiving
our friends at zerorez are here to help
it is so good to have our good friend
ben mckee the general manager
and operator of zerorez las vegas one of
my favorite places because
they keep my home so clean ben how are
the holidays looking for you guys i know
things have got to be busy right now
our schedules are jam-packed right now
but there's still time to get cleaned
before thanksgiving and definitely
before christmas and the rest of the
holidays coming up
tell us how zerorez is so
different from their competitors what we
do differently is
number one we have the best staff in las
vegas our
technicians our call center everybody is
trained
and they're trained to just make sure
that you have a great experience
as our customer we want you to be a part
of the zorres family
a second to all that we have the best
technology
carpet cleaners have been cleaning the
same way since like the 1940s
they use soaps they use surfactants and
those products cause
issues for your carpet that's why
carpets dry crunchy that's why spots
come back
and we've revolutionized carpet cleaning
where we don't use any of those
products we use alkaline water it's
actually a patented process
and as you know it leaves your carpet
soft it leaves your carpets cleaner
longer
and it's super safe for you and your
family i love that the other thing i
learned
is about the carpet being the largest
air filter in the house
and you don't think about that a lot all
the things that accumulate in there
it is collecting the dirt as collecting
dust is still collecting dead skin cells
and even you know regular vacuuming
that's a good way to get your carpets
cleaned and get that
you know that large air filter cleaned
up but there's no replacement for a good
carpet cleaning from zero res we can get
that air filter
basically cleaned so that it can go back
to doing its job of filtering
one thing i want to point out i had zero
res at my home not too long ago and the
safety measures that zerorez are taking
to make sure that you feel good about
letting someone in your your home has
been so great
it is it i get it we've we've got this
pandemic going on um
i would question bring a service person
into my home
but just rest assured as you are as we
are screening our employees daily
or even making sure that our customers
are feeling safe and
uh you know aren't having any symptoms
and we wear a proper ppe
we've got face masks we have shoe covers
and we have gloves as well
well we love what you guys do for las
vegas and you have a great special
you're actually partnering up for a
a very festive promotion this holiday
season let everyone know what they can
what they can get i know i'm excited for
that so right now you get three rooms of
carpet cleaning that's pre-treated
cleaned and zebra resified for only 99
and for a limited time we're going to
give away a free pass to glittering
lights
that is opening up soon up at the motor
speedway
so you can you know get your carpets
clean and have a
night out with the family again that's
three rooms of carpet clean for only 99
plus you're going to get that free any
day pass for glittering lights at the
las vegas motor speedway
call 702-840-3333 or go online
to zero zerorezlosvegas.com minimum
supply
las vegas now we'll be right back